- Comme on peut le voir,
on avait deux silos. Et puis,
le vent a pris dans le premier,
puis il l'a défait comme
un château de cartes.
- Pierre Chaumont peine
à croire ce qu'il voit.
Plusieurs bâtiments sur sa ferme
ont été détruits par la tempête.
- Toute cette bâtiss
a avancé de deux pieds
sur ses fondations.
On peut voir la fondation
qui est là. La grange a levé
puis elle a avancé.
- Les dommages sont évalués
à plusieurs centaines de
milliers de dollars, selon lui.
PIERRE CHAUMONT, agriculteur
- C'est un peu de la désolation.
C'est tout ce qui va vencccc
après, tous les problèmes qui
viennent avec ça et le travail.
- L'agriculteur et père
de famille n'aura pas le choix
que de se tourner vers
sa compagnie d'acececece puisque
Québec ne prévoit pas indemniser
les personnes touchées.
JONATAN JULIEN, ministre,
Énergie et Ressources naturelles
- Il y a des assurances
individur r r r r rapport
aux maisons. Donc, pour les cas
qu'on vit actuellement, soit
les cas d'alimentation ou
des dégâts sur des maisons,
c'est les assureurs qui pr
le relais.
- Je pense que je suis bien
assuré. Mais j'espère que les
gens en général le sont aussi.
- À quelques kilom
de la ferme, les équipes
d'Hydro-Québec sont à l'oeuvre
depuis tôt ce matin. À l'échelle
de la province, 1200 techniciens
sont engagés danurururururse
contre la montre.
PIETRO SCIORTINO,
chef des travaux, Hydro-Québec
- C'est 16 heures par jour,
puis c'est un 8 heures de repos
que ça prend pour les gars.
C'est sûr qu'il y a un minimum
esesesesess, t'sais, qu'on vit
à travers ça. Mais un coup
que tout, ensemble, en équipe,
tous les travailleurs,
plusieurs têtes à l'effort,pupue
super bien.
- Dédedededededes foyers touchés
par les pannes de courant
ont pu être rebranchés.
- On vise 80 % et rapidement là,
si on peut se rendre dans
e e e e e e 90 %, 95 %...
- Hydro-Québec ignore toujours
à quel moment le courant
sera complètement de retour
dans la province puisqueaiaiaiat
plus difficiles d'accès.
- C'est sûr que c'est plus
compliqué quand il y a beaucoup
de boisé, comme, je vous
expliquais, t'sais, de remonter
le fil quand il y a des
c'est assez compliqué aussi, là.
- Hydro-Québec demande
à la population d'éviter
de s'approcher des fils au sol.1
pour faire sécuriser les lieux.
Ici Hadi Hassin, Radio-Canada,
à Sainte-Anne-des-Plaines